hey I'm Constance Wu and I play Rachel
and I'm your going out playing Nick
Young hi I'm Jonathan and I play Astrid
I'm Michelle Yeoh and I play pillar know
young we are going to be doing a quiz to
figure out what character we should be
yeah we should have been
all right so pick a delicious
Singaporean dessert do you know all of
them I've tried like three of them our
options here are pandan cake ting ting
ice to judge know which one of these
have you had I've had most of them I
have had none of them I would think I
would choose this challenge on the one
because it looked like Hong dal which is
which is you know a thing I had and then
anxious I'm gonna go for pandan cake
I've got to say pandan cake which is
like it's like eating a cloud and like
soft fluffy delicious cloud that shaved
ice ice car Chong that's very very
popular you're on vacation which of the
following would you most likely be found
doing parasailing snorkelling reading
sightseeing eating everything and
sleeping
I've never parasailed I'm like site soon
you gotta go out and explore the city
for me for sure I want to sightsee but I
also want to snorkel if the water is
beautiful right it's the eating it's
definitely eating
I'm gonna go snorkeling it's not going
cuz I like fish choose a glamorous
outfit a suit a suit oh really oh yeah I
like I just like to our suit for a day
you know what I would but none of these
are double-breasted which I'm into I
think it's like manly I'm gonna go for
the summery suit you know what I've been
really into pink lately you know that uh
I guess the glittery pink other more
more dance when is not something I'm
gonna go for number four I like a light
suit what's the most important trait you
look for in a best friend so since
you're a reliable honest a little bit
weird good less than generous all of the
above all of the above can't have one
without the other right reliable for me
reliable if you only have you can only
choose one can I guess
I was gonna say obviously sense of humor
but then I saw a little bit weird and
I'm like yeah a little bit weird which
emoji really speaks to you okay
oh yeah click on for the kiss oh you
don't have the one with the glasses
that's my the one that's cursing that's
me no no doubt the T from the glasses my
doing it I'm stuck it's too tough I'm
gonna say probably the blasphemous one a
swearing blow any kiss finally pick a
place to buy your second home New York
City Singapore London Hong Kong Taiwan
or Sydney well Sydney half of my friends
live in New York City because I live
there for a long time so you're gonna
have to go in New York City I'm gonna
choose New York
[Laughter]
I can't Erin in saline how do I get
Burnet I you get along with people who
go above and beyond to show kindness but
you also really value your independence
and strength
it's totally the opposite of myself I'm
a teacher do jazz hands while you're
eating this you're someone who goes
above and beyond the call of duty to
show your appreciation to your friends
best of all you're not afraid to try new
things and seek adventures in new places
like BuzzFeed quizzes tell you who you
really are in yourself I just so much
about myself accept it I'm annoying I'll
accept that but someone who is earnest
loyal and honest but if someone crosses
you prepare for the work don't do this
silly friendly and down for any kind of
venture you are the lovely Araminta
brilliant it's you're a real social why
okay stop
you're the type of person who warmly
welcomes new friends into your circle
because you radiate kindness let's be
Senoia Jamie I love you man but you
don't want to be you and Senoia I love
you and I want to be I got you
[Music]